thousands of people in Europe suffer
from an addiction an addiction that has
repercussions not only on their health
but also on their wallets an addiction
that defies reason and seems to be
difficult to beat who they cannot do
without their cars even for extremely
short journeys and yet we do not have to
give up our cars completely we just need
to get out of the habit of using them
automatically the idea is that by
getting the right mix between driving
public transport cycling and walking we
will notice the benefits very quickly
for example by walking an average of
half an hour per day we prolong our life
expectancy by between two and nine years
strengthen 200 muscles and burn three
kilograms of fat per year it's there for
good for the heart and lungs as well as
being good for our physical appearance
by getting the right mix you can easily
save one full tank of fuel
every month which is not peanuts you
could spend the money you save on
something more enjoyable
by doing the right mix we also make
savings for our cities it has been
calculated that each kilometer we travel
by car costs our city nearly 1 euro in
various costs that is money that the
city could spend on projects to benefit
the community by doing the right mix we
make our cities more enjoyable places to
live
fewer traffic jams less pollution less
greenhouse gas emissions for example a
bus journey uses 20 times less urban
space than the same journey by car and
if we make a three kilometer journey on
foot or by bicycle instead of by car
each of us reduces his co2 output by one
kilogram so do you need any more reasons
to kick the addiction you'll feel better
and the planet will too
let's do the right mix